ja willkommen zur aktuellen Vorlesung
heute möchte ich wie immer zu Beginn
nochmal das begriffsnetz Ihnen
vorstellen das begegnets wird von
Sitzung der Sitzung von Vorlesung zu
Vorlesen dichter und irgendwann ist es
ein ganz schön engmaschiges Netz was
sehr sehr tragfähig ist das heißt aber
dass sie gerne auch an diesem Netz mit
knüpfen dürfen sowohl jetzt hier eine
Vorlesung als auch dann auf Youtube ich
habe jetzt mal ein bisschen was
multipliziert und zwar habe ich jetzt zu
oberst jetzt hier mal ähm nicht nur
Personen hingeschrieben sondern auch
Person oder menschliches Tier das wird
zurück auf einige ersten Vorlesung wo
wir darüber diskutiert haben ich setze
jetzt aber meinen Folgen an der Person
an also mache ich da jetzt für
Abzweigung individuelle Person geht
vielleicht auch kollektive Person kann
man darüber diskutieren wäre mögliche
Frage des Typs
dann haben wir die Handlung ins Zentrum
gestellt und jetzt gibt's das ist jetzt
auch neu also sagen jetzt gibt es
komplexe Handlungen und es gibt
basishandlungen was eine basishandlung
ist ist eine mögliche Frage des Typs
übrigens finden Sie alle Folien wie
immer auf Ilias sie können sich die
jetzt schon herunterladen
dann gibt es auch spezielle Formen von
Handlungen nehme ich zum Beispiel
Sprachhandlungen und da werden wir heute
drauf zu sprechen kommen aber erst
nachdem wir genügend Zeit für Diskussion
eingeplant hat dann gibt es den
willensbegriff und der muss von Begriff
des Wunsches unterschieden werden wieder
eine mögliche Frage des Typs
dann gibt es den Grundbegriff das heißt
der Wille wird häufig auch mit Gründen
in der Verbindung gebracht und da wo wir
keine Gründe im Spiel haben daran dass
die Bluse Willkür zu tun so kann man
jedenfalls den Begriffe verstehen
geht es weiter Vernunft wir haben
instrumentelle hypothetische imperative
Vernunft Mittel zum Zweck und wir haben
moralische Vernunft oder in
kategorischen Imperativ nach Immanuel
Kant die Vernunft die Rationalität steht
im Gegensatz zum Problem der
Willensschwäche darüber haben wir
ausführlich diskutiert Irrationalität im
Handeln inwiefern gibt es eigentlich
ja dann kann man jetzt hier noch einen
weiteren großen Problembereich aufmachen
nämlich die freiheitsdebatte und darauf
wollen wir auch heute mehr eingehen also
es geht um an die Freiheit die man
erstmal den positiven und negative
Freiheit unterscheiden kann und wir das
wäre zum Beispiel auch eine spannende
Frage des Jobs aber es ist der
Unterschied zwischen positiv und
negativen
dann kann man jetzt hier die positive
weite unterscheiden Handlungsfreiheit
und in Willensfreiheit auch wie schon
sagt ermögliche Fragen des Typs a dann
kann man zur Willensfreiheit noch den
Begriff der Autonomie hinzugesehen
darauf werden heute auch noch zu
sprechen kommen ganz wichtiger Begriff
und die Freiheit steht in einer Spannung
zu den Begriffen von der termination
Notwendigkeit und Indifferenz das sind
alles so Begriffe die irgendwie uns
Probleme machen wenn wir sie bestimmen
wollen wir kommen darauf noch genau zu
sprechen das Problem besteht darin
wie können wir die Freiheit die
Willensfreiheit mit einer vollständigen
Definition als vollständigen kausalen
Geschlossenheit
Bestimmtheit der Welt uns denken sie
Naturgesetze und das ist vielleicht noch
ihr möglich aber Ding ist ja
Notwendigkeit Notwendigkeit oder zwangen
wie soll Freiheit willenfreiheit mit
Zwang oder mit Notwendigkeit eine
Verbindung gestellt werden können hängt
natürlich immer davon abwaschen
Notwendigkeit steht wir kommen noch
genauer drauf und dann gibt es noch den
Begriff der Indifferenz wie soll
Freiheit mit bloßer
bloßem Gleichgewicht der völligen
Unentschiedenheit mit dem Gleichgewicht
der willenswaage denken immer diese
Waage wie soll Freiheit damit vereinbar
sein mit Indifferenz als Indifferenz
wäre jetzt praktisch so das Gegenteil
von determination ein Wille ist bestimmt
oder ein Wille ist unbestimmt dann ist
er eben Indifferenz und darin also haben
wir jedenfallsituation kann Freiheit
eigentlich auch nicht liegen ja das wäre
zum Beispiel Frage das warum was ist das
Problem wenn wir Freiheit als
Indifferenz annehmen oder als
äquilibringen da kann man auch
verschiedene Gründe dafür finden jetzt
kann man hier noch zwei große Positionen
unterscheiden nämlich den
kompatibilismus und dem
inkompatibilismus diese Begriffe habe
ich das letzte Mal gebracht die werden
heute auch im Zentrum stehen und man
kann ähm ich sag mal was zu
kompatibilismus kompatibilismus bedeutet
einfach etwas ist ineinander kompatibel
es verträgt sich miteinander es ist
zusammen bestehend Widerspruchs bei
denkbar und ein kompatibilismus wäre zum
Beispiel bezogen auf die Freiheit unser
freie Wille ist mit der determination
mit der vollständigen göttination der
Welt
kompatibel also es gibt Freiheit obwohl
die Naturgesetze alles bestimmen
Freiheit Willensfreiheit ist möglich
obwohl die Natur und wir auch weil wir
natürlich wissen sind sondern ständig
durch die Naturgesetze bestimmt trotzdem
sagen die listinnen und kompatibilisten
trotz dieser naturgesetzlichen
alles was passiert auch unsere
Behandlung sind wir willensfrei das ist
eine sehr anspruchsvolle these und wir
werden heute noch ein bisschen mehr
darauf eingehen und dagegen gibt es
jetzt aber die Position der
inkompatibilisten und die sagen nein der
termination oder Determinismus und
Willensfreiheit die sind grundsätzlich
nicht vereinbar wir kriegen die nicht
auf dem gemeinsamen Nenner und zwar aus
zwei möglichen Gründen es gibt jetzt
zwei mögliche Gründe warum man
argumentieren das Willensfreiheit nicht
mit der termination kompatibel ist und
zwar ein Grund ist ja dass man sagt ja
deswegen nicht weil einfach der
Determinismus war ist weil einfach es
gibt eben ein Determinismus und der ist
so hart dass der hart Determinismus dass
wir deswegen uns keine Willensfreiheit
denken können der harte determinist wir
kommen heute noch drauf am Beispiel der
Hirnforschung es gibt ein berühmten
Forscher der Wolfinger und der hat
gesagt wir sind deterniert durch unsere
organischen Prozesse und deswegen müssen
wir unsere Freiheit ja schwächer fassen
oder vielleicht sogar ein manchen Dingen
aufgeben und dann gibt's auch den
libertavianismus der sagt jetzt
Willensfreiheit und der terminismus sind
nicht vereinbar aber deswegen weil der
terminismus falsch ist ja er sagt es
gibt gar keine vollständig definierte
Welt die Naturgesetze der terminieren
gar nicht alles so vollständig dass
darin nicht noch Platz für Freiheit wäre
das heißt wie die libertarianer die
würden immer versuchen Lücken in der
Gesetzlichen determination aufzufinden
in die der freie Wille hineinpasst das
Problem ist dass man damit natürlich
immer so ein bisschen von Indifferenz
wieder annehmen muss und das führt
wieder in die bekannten Probleme also
das ist jetzt so diese diese
begriffskarte die ich Ihnen jetzt noch
mal vorstellen wollte sie finden die
alle auf diesen Folien und jetzt machen
wir wieder eine kleine
Diskussionsrunde weil das natürlich auch
diskutabel ist
ja wir haben noch als Ergänzung zu
diesem Betriebsnetz gesehen dass man
hier bei dem kategorischen Partie noch
ein Widerspruchs Pfeil oder ein Konflikt
Pfeil zur Philosophie von machen könnte
der behauptet hatte das ist keine
moralische 5 gibt das ist nicht unsere
fünf widerspricht wenn ich die
Vermeidung eines kleinen ritzes im
Finger an dem Untergang der ganzen Welt
wird sie also wenn ich praktisch lieber
den Untergang der ganzen Welt möchte als
ein Rätsel einen kleinen Finger das sagt
der wird widerspricht nicht unserer
Familie natürlich spannend ja also das
ist jetzt und hypothetische und
kategorische imperative kann man als
Beispiele der instrumentellen
ja jetzt geht es weiter in der
Debatte jetzt möchte ich Ihnen ein neues
Thema zeigen dass mit dem Rückblick
zusammenhängt und zwar hatten wir das
metallungsfreiheit zu tun also nochmal
ganz kurz Handlungsfreiheit heißt tun
können was man will steht im Gegensatz
zu Willensfreiheit und da habe ich
gesagt wollen können was man will das
natürlich jetzt ein bisschen paradox
aber so muss man es doch konstruieren
weil Harry Frank wird den sie schon mal
kennengelernt hatten der sagt dann wenn
wir fragen ob eine Person einen freien
Willen hat dann fragen wir nicht danach
ob Sie in der Lage ist ihre Wünsche
erste Stufen die Tat umzusetzen das wäre
die Frage ob sie frei ist zu tun was ihr
gefällt die Frage nach der
Willensfreiheit betrifft nicht dass das
Verhältnis zwischen dem was die Natur
tut und ihm was er tun möchte sondern
sie betrifft die wünschen selber es geht
nicht um das Verhältnis von Wille und
Handlung also die Frage kann der Wille
in die Handlung überführt werden es geht
darum kann ich diese Wünsche will und
nicht kontrollieren und sie zu meinen
Handlungsmotiven machen das ist die
Frage und hat noch ein Zitat das ist
ganz wichtig es erscheint mir nahelegen
und auch nützlich die Frage ob jemand
einen freien Willen hat möglichst genau
in Analogie zu der Frage zu konstruieren
ob jemand Handlungsfreiheit genießt nun
ist Handlungsfreiheit jedenfalls die
Freiheit zu tun was man tun möchte und
können was man entsprechend besagt die
Behauptung dass sich jemand eines freien
Willens freut jedenfalls überwiesen dass
er frei ist zu wollen was er wollen
möchte
genauer heißt das dass er frei ist den
Willen zu haben den er haben möchte also
sie können Willensfreiheit ganz analog
verstehen zu Handlungsfreiheit ja beim
Handeln handlungsfall kann ich das tun
was ich tun will wenn Handlungen bei der
Willensfreiheit kann ich wollen dass ich
etwas will ich kann meinen Willen selbst
noch mal bestimmen und das ist jetzt so
die Ausgangsbasis für die heutige
Wiederholung John Lock hatten sie schon
mal kennengelernt der hat eben
verschiedene Argumente gegen die
Willensfreiheit vorgebracht also
Argumente um zu bestreiten dass wir
wieder ins freien genannt werden können
das ist ein freien will gibt und sie
ahnen schon das ist eine Frage des Trips
also ich könnte jetzt zum Beispiel
Fragen
nennen sie
Argumente
die
gegen die Annahme der Willensfreiheit
ins Feld führt ja und da könnte ich auch
mir vorstellen so vier Punkte zu gehen
würde ich jetzt das ist alles ganz klar
eigentlich wir wiederholen es jetzt
heute noch mal und diskutieren auch
drüber also ich präsentiere die noch mal
eben jetzt reformiert und nicht mehr
anhand der langen Zitate unsere Freiheit
sagt Blog ist es ist völlig genügend zu
tun können was man will wenn ich was
will dann will ich was was soll ich denn
da noch wollen ich will was und dann
will ich dass sie die Handlung befinden
wieso soll ich denn da normalen Willen
befragen
ich will was ist es doch mein Wille und
jetzt soll der Wille in eine Handlung
überführt werden also man könnte sagen
dass das Argument
der der
genügenden Bestimmtheit von
Handlungsfreiheit also Willensfreiheit
wäre praktisch übermäßig anspruchsvoll
ist ist gar nicht erfordert das stellt
sich pragmatisch gar nicht und ich würde
auch sagen wenn sie mal eine Umfrage
machen auf der Straße und den Menschen
beliebigen Menschen die Frage vorsetzen
würden Sie sagen dass ich dann frei sind
wenn Sie tun können was sie wollen
würden Sie sagen dass das die volle
Freiheit ist oder würden Sie sonst noch
eine Freiheit fordern dann würden
behaupte ich mal 95%, wenn es nicht
gerade Philosophen im Philosophen sind
die hier in der Vorlesung waren würden
sagen ja das genügt vollkommen ich habe
will was und ich kann es eine Handlung
führen perfekt was soll ich denn da noch
zusätzlich wollen ja also das sagt
jedenfalls ist schon Lock hat noch ein
Argument er sagt der Wille kann deswegen
nicht frei genannt werden weil er kein
Subjekt ist also kein Akteur dem man
kann ja Akteuren Eigenschaften zu
sprechen und er ist auch keine Substanz
also zum Beispiel ein Ding was auch
Eigenschaften haben kann also dieses
Pult und das ist eine Substanz ist geil
aber so kann ich nicht den Willen
verstehen wie ein Kult äh dem ich dann
noch die Eigenschaften nicht Geld
sondern frei zu sprechen es geht nicht
und zwar deswegen weil der Wille eben
keine Substanz ist sondern eine Kraft
und insofern als Kraft nur eine
Kräfte sind nur Eigenschaften und
Eigenschaften können keine Eigenschaften
haben und zwar ist der Wille eine Kraft
oder eine Eigenschaft des Menschen der
Mensch und die Person kann man wieder
darüber diskutieren der ist der Akteur
die Akteurin der eigentlich freien
werden kann und nicht erwähnen das ist
praktisch das dritte Punkt nicht der
Wille ist frei sondern Mensch nur der
Mensch kann angemessen frei genannt
werden und schon laut bringt dir schöne
Beispiele sagt den Wille 13 bedeutet so
viel wie zu fragen ob das ob der Mond
formuliert ist mein freiraumwohnung ob
der Mond heute hungrig ist das genau
ähnlich nicht genau dasselbe ist nicht
genau dasselbe weil der Mond ist
natürlich eine Substanz die
Eigenschaften haben kann er will damit
nur sagen es ist ein Kategorienfehler
also ich kann diese Begriffe nicht so
anwenden weil sie einfach sich
eigentlich widersprechen das ist nicht
direkt die richtige Sprachverbindung
wenn ich frage oder wenn ich sage dass
der Dinge frei ist dann kommt noch
Interessantes augmente das finde ich
persönlich das Spann besser gesagt wenn
wir unseren Willen bestimmen können
wollten oder müsste um frei zu sein so
müssten wir immer einen noch höheren
wählen ausbilden weil wir sagten ob ich
nicht den Willen zweiter Stufe der
Meinung der erste Stufe dafür gibt ob
ich den nicht nochmal von der dritten
Stufe aus reflektieren können müsste und
wenn wir das jetzt so annehmen dann
gehen wir nie zu einer Entscheidung dann
können Sie bis uns unendliche weitere
hörstufe gewinnen ausbilden das ist das
Problem des Regresses wir haben darüber
diskutiert ob man vielleicht auch als
Zirkel verstehen kann der Wille dreht
sich ja nur im Kreis ja aber kann man
über diskutieren ich würde sagen es ist
mein Regress weil das immer weiter sich
steigert und wir nie an ein Ende kommen
so können Sie sich also dieses Argument
merken da machen wir jetzt natürlich
gleich auch eine Diskussion dazu aber
dann möchte ich noch einen weiteren
Punkt von Lock bringen
trotz allem auch noch so eine ganz
rudimentäre Form von lebensverhältnis
hat nämlich die Quelle der Freiheit wir
besitzt in unser Geist bei der
Verwirklichung und Befriedigung
irgendeines Wunsches innezuhalten und
mit allen anderen Wünschen der Reihe
nach ebenso zu verfahren und sie zu
betrachten unsere Wünsche und sie von
allen Seiten zu prüfen und gegeneinander
abzuwinkeln das heißt hier kann ich
nicht einfach was in mir
tätig erstmal zurück und frage mich will
ich das denn wirklich ja sie haben
verschiedene Wünsche begehrungen in sich
vielleicht auch ein Willen und der Wille
der geht schon fast zur Handlung über
und dann sagt jetzt schon noch ich finde
es sehr treffen sie können sich selbst
dann wenn sie in ganz festen eigentlich
Entschluss schon irgendwie gefasst haben
können sie eigentlich immer noch mal
zurücktreten und sagen Moment ich
betrachte das Ganze noch mal in ganz
anderen Licht ja ich mache mir selbst
mal ein Bild ja könnte sich auch ganz
anders sein und das finde ich sehr zuf
helfen das nennt man die Aufschiebung
des Willens Aufschiebung heißt auch
irgendwie Hemmung psychologisch könnte
man vielleicht sagen inhibition ist ja
auch eine kognitive Fähigkeit dass man
nicht allen Wünschen oder Begehrung
gleich nachgibt sondern dass man erst
mal Moment ich dreht mal zurück und
betrachte diesen einer gewissen
reflexiven Distanz bevor ich mich dann
entscheide und das ist eigentlich nichts
anderes als das was auch Harry Frank
wird gefordert hatte für die Freiheit
des Lebens durch sein Begriff der
volition zweiter Stufe
genau hier sagt jetzt log in diesem
unterbrechen in diesem Unterbrechen des
Wunsches
scheint in die Quelle aller Freiheit zu
liegen hierhin scheint das zu bestimmen
was man seines Erachtens unzutreffen
tief den freien Willen mensch das ist
also jetzt die eigentlich Definition der
Willensfreiheit wenn man überhaupt davon
reden kann macht schon locken wir machen
jetzt wieder eine kurze
diskussionseinheit dazu
ja dann geht es weiter wir haben uns mit
dem Problem der
handlungsfrei befasst und jetzt soll es
weitergehen zum Thema Willensfreiheit
das ist jetzt kann ich schon mal sagen
die viel anspruchsvollere Konzeption
Willensfreiheit ist viel schwieriger
kompatibilistisch zu verstehen weil sie
eben anspruchsvoller ist leider noch
viel mehr garantiert sein muss dann sich
kompatibilistisch verstehen kann also
dass ich lebensfreiheit mit der
determination vereinbaren kann mit der
naturgesetzlichen z.B also willensfrei
bestehen im Gegensatz zu
Handlungsfreiheit darin unseren Willen
selbst zu bestimmen wollen können was
ich will Ding sie an peripher diese
Analogie hier der Name gemacht hat es
genügt bei der bildungsverhältnis nicht
zu tun was man will
es genügt noch nicht für die Theorie der
Handlungszeit sondern unser Wille muss
kritisch geprüft und reflektiert werden
ist das was ich will wirklich mein
eigener Wille das ist die Frage die
dahinter steht also ich habe mir
verschiedene Wünsche vielleicht auch ein
Wille aber ich kann da immer noch mal
zurücktreten hinter den Willen und mich
fragen
ist es eigentlich mein Innerstes mein
eigenes was diese Willen sein Ausdruck
findet
daran setzt die Situation an weil man
könnte nämlich sagen wir müssen selbst
Ursachen unseres wollen sein und nicht
nur unsere Handlung ja wir müssen selbst
ursächlich auch für unseren Willen sein
wir dürfen unseren Willen nicht als
selbstverständlich voraussetzen und dann
noch fragen wie kann ich diesen Willen
diese begehrungen diese Willen sind
jetzt überführen das geht einfach um die
Frage kann ich mich auch als
selbstübersichtlich bewegen
eine Ebene tiefer die fragt immer viel
grundsätzlich es könnte nämlich sein so
dass Argument von verschiedenen
Vertreterinnen und Vertretern
manipuliert wurde und der gar nicht
unser eigene Wille ist zum Beispiel
durch Hirnwäsche oder soziale
Beeinflussung es ist ein
Gedankenexperiment möglich wo sie einen
Willen eingepflanzt bekommen der gar
nicht ist aber sie unterliegen der
Täuschung dass dass ihr wieder sagt kann
man sich vorstellen ja dass der wieder
den sie haben gar nicht von ihm selbst
gemacht wurde gebildet da waren sie
manipuliert kann man sich vorstellen
dass man in ihnen in Wünsche eingibt zum
Beispiel durch
kann man sich verschiedene überlegen
durch Hypnose oder so psychologische
Faktoren dass man ihnen wählen
suggeriert oder denken Sie mal an diese
Schleichwerbung oder versteckte Werbung
wenn man im Kino jedes ähm 24 Bild eine
Limonadenflasche ein einblendet da hat
man verschiedene psychologische
Experimente gemacht sie können Ihr
wollen und Ihren Wünschen manipuliert
werden das heißt die Intuition der
Willensfreiheit sagt wir müssen
sicherstellen dass der Wille wirklich
von uns kommt ja er darf nicht von
jemand anderem das wäre Fremdsteuerung
wir müssen ganz ganz
selbstbestimmt auch wenn sich das Willen
zahlen und jetzt kann man sich die Frage
wie man jetzt sich dann willenseits
vorstellen muss genauer erklären durch
den Begriff der Autonomie
Autonomie heißt jetzt als eine Form von
Willensfreiheit als Autonomie drückt den
Gedanken
wir müssen uns selbst die Gesetze
unseres Handelns und Wollens geben also
wir müssen bestimmen nach wie ich ihn
wir handeln und auch wollen was uns
praktisch die Orientierung gibt die
Prinzipien unseres Wollens und Handelns
jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen
inwiefern sind wir frei uns die Gesetze
unseres Wollens und Handelns zu geben
Autonomie bedeutet
Selbstgesetzgebung an sich selbst ein
Gesetz geben und zwar nicht irgendein
Gesetz weil dann wäre es ja wieder
fremdgesetzgebung wenn ich mir jetzt
irgendwie ein Gesetz zu eigen macht dann
kann ich dieses Gesetz zwar sympathisch
finden
aber es ist trotzdem nicht von mir
selbst entstanden ich habe dieses Gesetz
selbst mir nicht so gegeben dass es mein
eigenes Gesetz ist ich habe es
vielleicht zu eigen gemacht alles
gesetzt stand nicht aus mir sondern
jemand anderen der mir dieses Gesetz
angeht und der ganz starke Gedanke von
Autonomie bedeutet dass dieses Gesetz
auch selbst nur aus mir stand also ich
gebe mir ein Gesetz das schaut aus hier
und ich unterwerfe mich diesen Gesetz
zugleich auch noch mal das ist der
Gedanke der Autonomie also nicht
irgendwie angesetzt folgen sondern das
Gesetz muss aus mir selbst stammen und
stellst natürlich die Frage was bin ich
aus dem oder aus der dieses Gesetz Folge
bin ich ein Mensch ist hier oder bin ich
eine Person da fängt wieder die Frage an
was sie für eigentlich wir kommen jetzt
genau noch gleich zu sprechen auf an
gottfried Wilhelm Leibnitz ich möchte
trotzdem eine kurze Unterbrechung machen
und sie fragen ob sie dazu noch Fragen
haben zu dieser Intuition der
gegenüber der Handlungsfreiheit
jetzt kommen wir nämlich auf Leibnitz
noch mal kurz zu sprechen und dann wie
versprochen wird es weitergehen zum
Problem des
inkompatibilismus also Leibnitz ist ein
Zeitgenosse von John lock
und er hat in seinen neuen Abhandlung
über den menschlichen Verstand versucht
schon Loks Theorie der Handlungsfreiheit
zu widerlegen bzw zu ergänzen durch eine
Theorie der Willensfreiheit also
Leibnitz denkt wie nur wenige andere
Philosophen Willensfreiheit ganz streng
und ganz stark der argumentiert also im
Gegensatz zu machen
Willensfreiheit und er nimmt drei
Bedingungen für die will ins frei die
habe ich ins letzte auch schon genannt
und zwar Kontinents also dass die nicht
Notwendigkeit eigentlich bedeutet
Kontingent auch noch nicht und die nicht
Notwendigkeiten auch nicht auch die
nicht Unmöglichkeit also etwas ist
möglich nicht unmöglich und es ist nicht
notwendig ja also letztendlich ein
Bereich des sein Könnens ohne sein zu
müssen und nicht ja sein können ohne
sein zu müssen
weil auch das könnte man jetzt modal
logisch als Notwendigkeit ist eine
Modernität man kann sich jetzt darüber
überschreiten ob das was notwendig ist
auch möglich sein muss also für zu weit
Kontingenz kann sich einfach so merken
nicht Notwendigkeit
sondern es ist möglich das ist eine
Bedingung für die wir ins Freiheit also
wenn wir Notwendigkeit haben in der Welt
wenn alles notwendigerweise auf meine
folgt dann so Leibnitz dann hat Willen
Freiheit keinen Ort linksfreiheit gibt's
nur wenn wir Notwendigkeit vermeiden und
dann hat er hier ein Zitat gebracht und
es kann nicht ganz spannend er spricht
von geometrischen und metaphysischen
Konsequenzen also Folge Beziehungen die
einen Nötigung enthalten als eine
Notwendigkeit und er spricht dagegen
noch von physischen und moralischen
Folge Beziehung die zwar geneigt machen
oder auch determinieren aber nicht
nötigen ich hatte da gebracht als
Beispiel der geometrischen Notwendigkeit
z.B der Satz ist total groß dann können
sie notwendigerweise begründen sie
können begründen notwendig warum die
Winkelsumme des zweidimensionalen
Dreiecks 180 Grad ist das können sie
mathematisch mit zwingender
Notwendigkeit beweisen und Leibnitz sagt
auch so eine Notwendigkeit passt nicht
mit unseren bayernwellen zusammen da
geht es nicht um den mathematischen
notwendige Begründung sondern es geht
darum dass wir geneigt gemacht werden in
physischen und körperlichen und
moralischen Kontexten da sind wir
bestimmt da handeln wir nicht grundlos
aber wir handeln nicht gemäß der
Notwendigkeit wir brauchen da nicht
genauer darauf eingehen auf dieses Zitat
weil das viel zu kompliziert werde wäre
ich will noch einen weiteren Punkt
erwählen Intelligenz der liberation da
hat mir vorher Diskussion wie ist es
wenn ich immer weiter reflektieren man
will immer weiter von höheren Stufe
betrachtet könnte ich da nicht doch
sagen dass ich je mehr ich meinen Willen
vernünftige weißen kritisieren dass ich
umso weniger frei bin da haben wir noch
gewisse Intuition dafür und so macht
auch leiden gesagt Willensfreiheit
bedeutet dass ich immer delebrieren kann
dass ich also Gründe abwägen kann meine
Handlungsoption immer wieder im neuen
Licht von gewissen Gegenargumenten
kritisch reflektieren kann und er sagt
man wir brauchen Spontanität und das ist
jetzt diese bereits genannte
selbstursächlichkeit also alles muss aus
und selbst kommen und darf der Wille
nicht nur eingepflanzt sein oder darf
nicht nur hier sein sondern unser wollen
unser Handeln muss aus unserem eigenen
inneren aus dem herauskommen was wir
eigentlich sind wir müssen selbst die
Ursache von unseren Wollen und Handeln
zahlen damit versucht jetzt eben
Leibnitz diesem Manipulation Einwand z.B
gegeben
von uns aus eigenem
antriebskontanitätshaus einfach aus
einem Antrieb sowas konnte ins Latein
heißt eben das genau das sind es ist von
uns wir sind die Autoren unseres Wollens
und unseres
wir kommen gleich noch auf die Debatte
drüber genauer zu sprechen ich wollte
jetzt noch ein paar Punkte bringen also
wir sind nach Leibnitz vollständig
determiniert nicht Netze zitiert also
nicht Notwendigkeit herrscht aber
Bestimmtheit und sind dennoch frei warum
sind wir determiniert er sagt alles muss
dem Satz zum zureichenden Gründe Folgen
alles muss ein Grund haben das ist für
ihn ein Gesetz das muss gelten weil wenn
der Satz keine Geltung hätte könnten wir
die Welt gar nicht verstehen aber auch
unser Handeln alles was es gibt auch
alle menschlichen Angelegenheiten müssen
diesen Satz von zu reichenden alles hat
einen Grund den wir bestimmen können
müssen
folgen
und deswegen sagt uns der Wille darf
nicht als irgendein Vermögen ohne Grund
verstanden werden das wäre dann so eine
wirklich vernünftige unvermunft also
unsere Vernunft unserer Handeln unser
wollen muss immer bestimmten Gründen
Folge und deswegen vertritt jetzt
Leibnitz einen kompatibilismus von der
termination der terminismus
unsere Freiheit hat zu reich gegründe
und Willensfreiheit und ich hatte schon
darauf hingewiesen Immanuel Kant hat es
später kritisiert und hat gesagt das was
Leidenschaft vorstellt dass wir
determiniert sind und doch zugleich frei
das ist nichts anderes als die Freiheit
eines bratenwindes und darüber wollen
wir jetzt auch noch kurz diskutieren wie
man das verstehen kann
ich will damit nur sagen leid es macht
drei ganz starke Bedingungen namenhaft
Kontingenz Intelligenz und Spontanität
und es stellt sich wirklich die Frage
wie wir fontanität wie wir das mit der
determination kompatibilistisch
vereinbaren können ist eine riesen Frage
die müssen jetzt aber auch nicht genau
in diesem Seminar behandeln das wäre ein
Thema für einen anderen
okay ja dann geht's weiter
und zwar hatte ich das schon gebracht
bei Leibnitz dass er das sagt also
kompatibilismus ist vielleicht sehr
wichtig blieb nicht unwidersprochen
Immanuel kann dieser nicht hat das
bestritten und er hat stattdessen den
Begriff der Autonomie gebracht selbst
Gesetzgebung und ich hatte schon erzählt
Autonomie bedeutet nachkannt dass wir
unsere Maximen also unsere subjektiven
Handlungsgrundsätze nach moralischen
Regeln beurteilen und auch danach
ausrichten also wir fragen ob unsere
individuellen
Maximen also Handlungsgrundsätze ob die
an allgemeines vernünftiges Objekt
benötiges Gesetz werden könnten ob sie
sich vernünftig verallgemeinern lassen
und damit hat kann natürlich ein
objektives absolutes Kriterien Kriterium
um irgendwann zu sagen jetzt muss ich
nicht mehr meinen Willen weiter prüfen
wir sind endlich ihre Grenzen sagt
Moralität genügt dann bin ich am Ende
meiner Diensten angelangt und das Gesetz
der Autonomie den wir uns unterwerfen
sollen dass dieses Gesetz ist eben nicht
irgendein eingesetzt und das ist unser
eigenes Gesetz
und zwar nicht der fremdes Gesetz das
wäre Heteronomie sondern unser eigenes
Autos ist autonomist ist
Selbstgesetzgebung jetzt kann man sich
fragen wenn jetzt kann von eigenem
Gesetz spricht was sind wir eigentlich
um davon ausgehen bestimmt zu können was
unser eigenes Gesetz das ich kann doch
erst sagen das ist mein eigenes Gesetz
wenn ich weiß was ich selbst bin und
hier gibt es wie immer in der
Philosophie viele Möglichkeiten das zu
beantworten und kann sagen wir sind
menschliche Tiere die nach Glück streben
das ist der Mensch die menschliche Natur
Streben dann wird es ziemlich schwierig
sein eigenes Gesetz zu finden weil das
wäre dann das glücksgesetz das Gesetz
des größten Glücks und jeder sagt kann
von uns hat andere Vorstellung davon was
das größte Glück ist manche von uns
möchten die ganze Zeit Schokoladenkuchen
Essen manche möchten die ganze Zeit
Paprika Chips essen ja oder vielleicht
was anderes ja also sie können
Objektives Glück eigentlich gar nicht
wirklich bestimmt und deswegen wird sehr
schwierig uns als menschliche Tiere zu
verstehen und zugleichen Objektives
Gesetz damit zu verbinden das heißt wenn
es ein objektives Gesetz gibt es aber
nicht gesagt das ist es gibt aber wenn
es es geben soll dann dürfen wir nach
kann keine menschlichen Tiere sein
sondern sie müssen Personen sein
Personen sind vernünftige Wesen die
nicht
intrinsisch im Innersten nach
glückssteigerung streben die also nicht
nur instrumentelle Vernunft haben
sondern Wesen die im Grunde moralisch
sein wollen wir wollen im Grunde wenn
wir nur lange genug nachdenken kann
eigentlich moralisch handeln weil wir im
Grunde moralischen Dienst sind
wenn wir die starke these weil viele
Menschen denken sehr lange nach über das
was sie tun sollen und am Ende landen
sie nicht bei einer moralischen
Entscheidung das ist doch eigentlich
ziemlich klar das heißt es gibt
verschiedene Probleme der Autonomie z.B
wie können wir uns als Freiheit
eingesetzt geben wenn wir doch immer
schon unter einem Gesetz stehen müssen
frei zu sein also wie findet überhaupt
diese Art der Selbstgesetzgebung statt
dass Sie uns unter eingesetzt stellen
wenn wir doch im unter das Gesetz stehen
bis wir unter dem Gesetz stehen noch gar
keinen Gesetzen stehen da gibt es so
eine kleine Lücke das sogenannte paradox
der Autonomie also wir müssen eigentlich
immer schon in dem Gesetz stehen und uns
ein Gesetz geben zu können alles scheint
er seine kleine gesetzlose Lücke zu
geben in dem Moment wo wir uns das
Gesetz ist noch geben müssen so kann man
eines ein Problem sehen dann ist ein
großes Problem mit dem autonomengesetz
das hingesetztes an wie können wir uns
das vorstellen wenn die Gegend gesetzt
handeln was sind die Gründe dafür dass
sie gegen die Gebote
sind wir dann mal kurz und aufmerksam
gewesen und haben die vernünftige
stimmen uns überhört oder waren wir
wildschwach oder haben wir uns selbst
getäuscht ja das ist nach wie vor heißt
diskutierte Frage und eben die Frage
auch schon die ich schon genannt habe
sind wir im tiefsten innen wirklich
moralische Wesen so dass unser eigenes
das Gesetz unseres und Handels im Grunde
immer ein moralisches Gesetz ist oder
gibt es
wesenstrukturen von uns die einfach
nicht
moralisch aufgefasst werden müssen
nämlich zum Beispiel individuelle
wesenstrukturen Charakter hatten sie
genannt ja man Charakter ist natürlich
nicht immer ein
moralischer
Charaktere können ganz verschiedene sein
also das ist praktisch das Problem bei
Kant der Autonomie ich denke das sollte
es soweit klar sein und jetzt will ich
noch mal wiederholen die Sitzung ist
fast zu Ende deswegen wiederholen wir
hier noch schön
kompatibilismus und inkompatibilismus
gegenüberstellen also kompatibilismus
bedeutet Willensfreiheit ist mit der
determination z.B der vollständigen
naturgesetzlichen Bestimmtheit
vereinbaren also zum Beispiel könnte man
sagen Gründe im kompatibilistisch sind
Gründe die terminieren unser Handeln
aber Gründe sind nicht Natur kann
Ursachen dann wäre alles bestimmt aber
es gäbe noch Gründe und die Gründe
würden eine Sonderrolle spielen weil die
nicht in der Natur Ursachen zu verstehen
sind aber dennoch
handlungsbestimmende Faktoren das wäre
eine Möglichkeit dann müsste man
natürlich den Determinismus ein bisschen
abschwächen und noch sowas wie Gründe
dazu annehmen das machen sehr viele ja
viele andere Möglichkeit besteht darin
wie wir schon diskutiert haben bei
Leibnitz zu sagen die Bestimmtheit
unserer Welt auch durch Naturgesetze die
ist nur kontingenterweise so an die ist
nicht notwendiger also so es hätte auch
anders sein können es ist eine Welt
denkbar die ganz andere Naturgesetze hat
und deswegen ist unser Handel obwohl es
bestimmt ist nicht notwendig und dann
kann ich davon sprechen das ist frei ist
ja so einfach ist es natürlich nicht
aber so könnte man auch
kompatibilistisch argumentieren das
Problem ist eben dann können wir die
Realität von Gründen erklären
existieren Gründe so wie Naturgesetze ja
und wenn ja wie verhalten Sie sich
zueinander bin ich wenn ich mich mit
Gründen für eine Handlung bestimme dann
kurzzeitig der naturgesetzlichen
determination enthoben die über den
Naturgesetzen oder stehe ich zwischen
den Naturgesetzen weil die nicht ganz
genau alles der terminiert sondern
passen noch Gründe rein in diese
naturgesetzliche Kette Platz passen noch
Gründe rein die sich da hinein schmiegen
können in diese kausal Kälte der Natur
das ist so das Problem des
kompatibilismus oder gibt es problemlos
inkompatibilismus und das heißt einfach
allgemein Willensfreiheit ist mit
determination nicht vereinbar und dieses
nicht vereinbaren kann aus zwei Gründen
sein einmal weil einfach der
Determinismus war ist der ist da und
deswegen sind wir nicht mehr zwei es
geht dann harte Determinismus und viel
stärkeren Sinne als in sich jetzt
Leibnitz denkt ähm dann sind wir nicht
unsere Handlung verantwortlich das ist
Problem ja wenn haben der terminismus
annehmen und es gibt noch den
libertarianismus der sagt der dekanismus
ist falsch und deswegen sind Freiheit
ist wie ein Freiheit nicht mit der
Temperaturen vereinbar bitte Kommunismus
ist falsch es ist gar nicht so dass
alles total determiniert ist so ist es
gar nicht sondern es gibt Lücken es gibt
in differente Zustimmung zum Beispiel
die Kranken zustimmt und deswegen ist
Freiheit möglich weil der Determinismus
einfach nicht so existieren jetzt kann
man da natürlich kritisch einbinden ist
Freiheit dann mit den Indeterminismus
vereinbart mit einer Indifferenz oder
widerspricht nicht Indifferenz gerade
unserer Intuition von Freiheit und
Freiheit immer auch bestimmt sein muss
ja das ist der Punkt und jetzt gibt es
sogenannte Konsequenz Argument von Peter
van invegen das ist das Problem der
Deklination und zwar lautet das
folgendermaßen ich bringe jetzt mal die
deutsche national kann er sagt dann um
die vergangene Zeit nicht mehr in meiner
Gewalt ist z.B vor 100 Jahren wo ich
noch nicht geboren wurde so muss jede
Handlung die ich ausüben durch
bestimmende Gründe die nicht in meiner
Gewalt sind notwendig sein weil vor 100
Jahren habe ich noch nicht gelebt das
heißt ich bin in dem Zeitpunkt die darin
nicht handle niemals frei das ist
sogenannte konsequenzordnung ja ich bin
einfach vor 100 Jahren nicht aufgeregt
gewesen
kausale Ursachen die noch vor 100 Jahren
Geltung haben bestimmt mein Handel jetzt
also bin ich für meine Handlung jetzt
nicht verantwortlich weil es Gründe sind
die vor meiner Geburt lagen
Peter von inbeigen ein Bekannter
britischer Philosoph hat das so
formuliert das können sich noch mal in
aller Ruhe nachlesen auf den Folien das
ist genau dasselbe was Immanuel Kant
schon 200 Jahre vorher gesagt hatte das
ist das Problem und deswegen kommen
manche zur Auffassung willensverhalten
ist ein Mysterium also Peter von ihn
wegen dieser analytische Philosoph der
sagt der terminismus ist richtig und
freie Wille ist richtig aber die kriegen
wir nicht zusammen sagt er und deswegen
ähm ist der freiwillige ein Mysterium
wir haben die absolute Intuition dass es
ihm gibt den freien will alle spricht
dafür zugleich haben wir keine Argumente
gegen dieses Konsequenz Argument gegen
den terminismus eigentlich ist Freiheit
was widersprüchliches aber wir müssen
sie trotzdem annehmen und deswegen Karte
ist Freiheit ein Mysterium ein Mystery
darüber kann natürlich auch noch
spannend diskutieren und es gibt noch
andere Deterministen die noch viel
härter sind nämlich Wolf singer der hat
ein Aufsatz geschrieben ja 2004 in der
in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung
ist also schon sehr alt relativ alt aber
immer noch irgendwie aktuell und zwar
war der Titel keiner kann anders als er
ist all unser Denken und Tun ist mit dem
ablaufneuronaler Prozesse zu erklären
mein Wolf singer direktinstitut für
Hirnforschung in Frankfurt wir sollten
auch hören von Freiheit zu reden weil
alles in organisch festgemacht ist
genetische Faktoren früh Prägungen
soziale Lernvorgänge aktuelle Auslöser
zu den auch Befehle Wünsche und
Argumente andere zählen wirken stets
untrennbar zusammen und legen dass
ergebens fest gleich ob sich
Entscheidungen mehr unbewussten oder
bewussten Motiven verdanken sie
bestimmen gemeinsam die dynamischen
Zustände der entscheidende Nerven
reisewolf singer sagt wenn es um
Freiheit geht müsste nur in unser Gehirn
schauen und schauen was da passiert
genetische Dispositionen können
Verschaltungen hervorgebracht haben wie
das Speichern oder abrufen sozialer
Regeln erschweren oder sollten sozialen
Regeln wurden nicht rechtzeitig und tief
genug eingeprägt oder es wurden von der
Norm abweichende Regeln ernähren oder
die Fähigkeit zu rationalen Abwägungen
Intelligenz teleporation wurde wegen
fehlgeleiteter Prägung um genügend
ausdifferenziert diese Liste lese ich
nahezu beliebig verändern keiner kann
anders als sie ist aber sie sind nicht
ganz frei diese Einsicht das keine
anders kann als sie ist sagt jetzt mal
zu mir könnte zu einer humanerin weniger
diskriminierenden Beurteilung von
Mitmenschen führen die das Pech hatten
mit einem Organen volljährig geworden
ist strafmündig ist in vollen Sinne
dessen funktionelle Architektur ihn kein
angepasstes Verhalten erlaubt Mensch mit
problematischen Verhaltensdisposition
als schlecht oder böse abzuurteilen
bedeutet nichts anderes als das Ergebnis
einer schicksalshaften Entwicklung des
Organs dass unser Wesen ausmacht zu
bewerten also das Organ was unser Wesen
ausmacht ist jetzt nach wolfsinger unser
Gehirn Sie sehen ist es wirklich Frage
was sind wir eigentlich wir sind
eigentlich unser Gehirn Immanuel Kanzler
wir sind eigentlich moralische Vernunft
ja da sehen sie wie das hängt davon ab
was man glaubt dass wir sind sie können
sich das noch genauer anschauen was
jetzt eben auch Wolf singer fordert für
strafrechtliche soziale Konsequenzen aus
seiner Behauptung der Unfreiheit des
Willens der neurologischen determination
ist also ein inkompatibilist und ein
harter Details könnte man sagen ja wir
hatten drüber diskutiert sind wir wenn
zwei und trotz dieser einige Argumente
die es von Wolfinger haben sie nicht
gehört der letzten Sitzung vielleicht
würden sie jetzt anders entscheiden aber
sie haben zumindestens entschieden
mit einer gewissen sechs prozentigen
Mehrheit dass wir wenigstens frei sind
also sie haben wohl die Intuition dass
wir bzw sind ich würde interessieren
natürlich wie es nach der heutigen
Sitzung aussehe ob sie immer noch dieser
Meinung wären eigentlich wollte ich
jetzt heute das Thema sprachhandlung
machen ist es ziemlich kurz und das kann
man auch noch schön in einer
Online-Sitzung weitermachen wollt nur
sagen wir können nicht nur Handeln durch
unsere Hände oder durch unseren Willen
willenshandlung sondern wir können auch
durchsprechen
zum Beispiel Befehlen ernennen tauchen
gibt es ein schönes Buch ausziehen Auto
du Dings mit words also wir können mit
sogenannten sprech ab und das Speedtest
was tun wenn sie sagen ja ich will was
tun Sie damit
die sagen nicht dass sie das wollen
sondern sie gehen in bestimmten
Kontexten eine Ehe ein es müssen
aufpassen wenn Sie das sagen sie müssen
immer schauen in welchen Kontexten sagen
sie das ja und das ist nämlich eine
Handlung je nachdem in welchem Kontext
sie sagen ja ich will beibringen sie
eine Handlung die viele gravierende
Konsequenzen haben
kann oder ich Taufe diese Schiff auf den
grünen und dann schneiden Sie so eine so
eine shampoosflasche hin äh damit machen
sie auch ziemlich viel dieses Schiff
wird in der Zukunft immer diesen Namen
dran ne und das machen sie ohne dass sie
wirklich was machen sie bewegen nur ihre
Lippen und stoßen lauter aus ich mache
diese Uhr meiner Tochter annehmen das
können Sie auch hinschreiben können Sie
aber auch sagen und dann haben sie
ziemlich viel gemacht nicht nur paar
macht sondern sie haben damit eben
weitgehend Entscheidung getroffen das
sind durchaus Handlung ja und darauf hat
eben ausziehen hingewiesen dass wir
damit nicht nur beschreiben was wir tun
so wir tun selbst etwas indem wir das
sagen wenn er es sei
not report
also ich sage nicht über eine Hochzeit
Heirat aus sondern ich gehe diese Heirat
ein indem ich diese Worte verwendet ja
das war es nur kurz dazu wir gehen das
nächste mal ein bisschen näher drauf ein
sprachhandlung hängen natürlich immer
von gewissen Kontexten ab wenn ich jetzt
sage ich will ja ich will dann wirklich
gar nichts dann fragen nur was sagt der
hier eigentlich ne wenn ich das jetzt
aber in einem anderen Kontext Sage von
standesstandesbeamtin mit vielleicht
Zeugen Trauzeugen und so weiter dann hat
sie so ein Satz durchaus gewisse
Konsequenzen natürlich nur positiv ist
in der nächsten Sitzung werden uns mit
moralischen Gefühlen und Emotionen
befassen und zwar mit Harry Frank für
den sie schon mal kennengelernt haben in
einem Buch
löschen also er versucht jetzt
Notwendigkeit mit Freiheit zu verbinden
und zwar indem er sagt es gibt auch
zuständig der Liebe und die Liebe ist
für ihn ein Zustand der Freiheit der
absolut entschieden sind Freiheit die es
gibt warum weil wir da ganz verbindlich
sind und dem an uns und die andere
Person sorgen und das ist eine Form von
Notwendigkeit ja
dann bedanke mich für die Aufmerksamkeit